let me start with a just a little bit of
data if you take many of the
professional occupations these days you
know think of the law sector or medicine
or even our entry-level corporate
management I somewhere between a third
and a half of the entering class of you
know beginning managers and executives
will be female because guess what are
you know women are doing very well in
tertiary education they're about half of
all law school graduates there i think
thirty-seven percent of business school
graduates etc so there's lots of women
at the beginning ranks the problem is
they stall out we did a study at the
task force which was called on ramps and
off ramps and it was about how to deal
with the non-linearity of women's
careers and what we found in that study
is at about forty percent of highly
credentialed women on track ambitious
women who are committed to their careers
will voluntarily quit their careers for
a short period of time generally is the
second child not the first that pushes
them out now they're not out for a whole
lot of time on average just 2.2 years
but it's enough to kill their careers
because getting those on ramps to be a
little more fluid a little more
welcoming is a huge task because right
now it's very hard to get back in once
you leave because careers you know we're
set up in the 50s and 60s with just one
model with the lockstep you know
continuous cumulative progressions and
if you flout those rules you know you
can get kicked into oblivion pretty
quickly I mean we find in our data that
if you take three years out even if you
you know jump right back in and are very
committed you will lose thirty eight
percent of your earning power
permanently and then get clobbered
the same way it's you know it's the
nonlinearity it's the interruptions it's
the gaps in the resume that kill you not
the fact that your f-35 is a 35 year old
woman so I think I mean what where we
came to in this research is that one way
of making sure that there's lots of
great candidates for that vice president
position that happened to be women is
they do a much better job enabling women
either to continue to be attached to the
labor market say in their mid-30s or by
mechanism mechanisms of bringing them
back on you know over the last 23 years
as a result of this work we did five or
six new programs have been born that
deliberately reach out and an onboard
women who have just spent a couple of us
a involved in the work of care they've
been remarkably successful and they have
done a great job in making those slates
you know richer in great female
candidates because you know the fact is
again in the data we find that women on
average have nine years of our career
experience before they take that off
ramp and their performance evaluations
are actually better than the man that
they're competing with at that point in
time so you know a lot of the seeming
paucity of candidates has a lot to do
with what happens to crea pause in the
decade of 11 30s and what we've ended up
doing the task force is recommended a
better stab at giving women a second
shot at ambition because you know this
is precisely what they want
you